sexismus ist ein sensibles thema ich
wünschte ich könnte darüber jetzt mit
einem sensiblen experten sprechen aber
zeit hatte nur olaf schubert meine damen
und herren
oder ich habe es eben schon gesagt das
ist ja weiß gott nicht unsere erste
sexismus debatte diebe führen
wieso geht bei dem thema scheinbar
nichts voran es sind jahrhundertelange
zementierte strukturen und selbst eine
elementar forderung geht es wie die nach
einvernehmlichem geschlechtsverkehr das
ja ich meine einvernehmlicher
geschlechtsverkehr hat das wird auch für
filmstudio erst mal eine umstellung so
aber wir schaffen das also ich hab es ja
auch ich muss zugeben für mich war das
auch neue also ein von hinten liegen
sechs hatte ich noch nie
also es war immer gegen meinen willen
und deshalb muss ich da was bewegen
besser wäre es ist ja offensichtlich ein
maskulines problem was stimmt nicht mit
dem mann an sich
da kann man jetzt schwer für allgemein
und der mann hat schon
selbstverständlich nur so so so ein
flotter spruch oder mal einen klaps auf
den hintern und wenn wenn du das machst
dann fühlt sich die frau sexuell
belästigt völlig zu recht wenn ich das
mache find ich geil
man muss eben feststellen dass das
einfache man sich wirklich stellenweise
überschätzt und mit denen müssen wir
reden
dieses problem wo fängt für dich
sexismus an
da wird ja auch vieles fehlinterpretiert
manche aussagen also wenn ich jetzt
meine frau sage man du hast einen
schönen busen dann meine ich das jetzt
nicht sexistisch so nah ich würde das
auch zu man sagen ja aber naja da passt
eben leider nicht so richtig und ich
mache aber nun mal gerne komplimente
also ist erst mal bei dir im büro war
nicht da kam ich rein und er hat seinen
schreibtisch und dahinter war so eine
glasscheibe die schienen die sonne rein
so wunderschön ist indirektes licht und
hätte gesagt oliver du hast wunderschöne
ohren
na ja und da hat er gleich so tötet sind
und das ist das problem
viele menschen haben probleme mit
komplimenten gerade die hässlichen was
muss ich denn jetzt insgesamt ändern im
verhältnis und auch im rollenbild der
geschlechter dass die frau das ist ich
kann das nicht gutheißen dass die frau
immer noch wer hat ihre körperlichkeit
reduziert wird nur das sehen wir an den
zeitschriften immer immer ist eine frau
auf seine schlanke blonde stunde kaum
was anfiel aus wenig drunter nichts
drüber und dann hier mit müll sie oder
würde wird das irgendwie hört da wird
das rauskommt hedged mit dem ergebnis
dass machen denn die frauen im alltag
nach da wird der busen irgendwie hoch
gewichtet mit aller gewalt stellenweise
bis über die hüfte
und wo es nicht geht dann müssen wir
nachhelfen heute gehen sie in die
schönheitschirurgie wie man jetzt ja
sagt noch in die änderungs fleischerei
da erwarte ich von den frauen mehr
selbstbewusstsein dass man das einfach
mal baumeln lässt dass man das ist das
was wir aus der debatte lernen können
finde ich ist es müssen sich alle
bewegen der mann wird nicht groß kommt
aber mit die weiber können ja wenn ich
mal führen permanent blöd rumzicken dann
wäre schon viel gewonnen so ein
wertvoller debattenbeitrag olaf schubert
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]